Now when we know how to time
an operation an operation in
Python let's check how fast Num-Py is.
Let's define a really large array so
that the time taken for
the operation will be
significant to compare.
So here is our large array of
1,000 rows and 10,000 columns.
Before I go ahead,
I would like to mention
that this is just a demo code
to show the speed of Num-Py.
So, I will be giving a high
level explanation of this code.
Moving ahead, we will be comparing
how to compute mean of the array
using Num-Py and
using standard iteration.
Here is the manual mean function
which computes the mean of the values
in the defined area.
We trade over each row, and for
each row it trade over each column.
We then sum present all
the values throughout the array.
Finally, we divide by the size of
the array and hence we get the mean.
In case of using Num-Py for
calculating the mean,
we just write array.mean to get
the mean of the entire array.
How long function will just compute
the time each matter takes.
Now, let's check what's
the time difference.
Do you see the difference?
This is the time taken by
the numpy.mean function
to calculate the mean
of the entire array.
And remember the size of
the array are in thousands.
On the other hand, the time taken by
the manual method is about 5 seconds.
Hence proved, Num-Py is super fast.
We also compute the rate of how fast
the Num-Py is and the numbers are crazy.
It's about 290 times faster
than the manual for loops.
Observe that Num-Py not only makes
the code more cleaner as compared
to the manual method, but there's about
290 times faster than other method.
Don't you think it's just awesome?